hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to raft now if you
remember raft it was an exercise in to
seeing how lonely and crazy I could get
on my own in the middle of the ocean but
this game has been extremely updated
many of you are like oh it just ended at
1.05 back in the beta but in actuality
this game has been worked on non-stop
ever since oh I get to grab my own
character oh I could choose between Maya
Andrew hey Maya Ruby Maya Ruby my Ruby
my Ruby my Ruby my really really my room
my room I owe me money do I can't make a
decision on my own why is this such a
tough decision for me I died usually I'm
just like oh you can pick one or the
other but uh no no no I'm crippled with
indecision I did
I'm not joking I'm not doing this for a
bit I brie lies I just why is this so
hard for me why is this so hard this
this shirt says number one I'm number
one this shirts just a cool button-up x
prime a cool button-up there's jamya
god dammit that was so hard let's see um
let's see ah world name okay alright
allow friends join I don't have any
friends alright let's do this we're all
Oh Jenkins okay there we go oh okay I am
late in it whoa Wayne how you doing
Wayne huh oh I remember now
I remember how this game goes now oh
yeah it's the same oh yeah Oh get ready
for a whole lot of me being lonely
no okay oh god I'm Duane don't even
think about it Wayne oh oh
bird he's above the table man I
shouldn't see ah but sash shouldn't sing
so good or else I'll get a copyright
claim but [ __ ] you
what pity tits did that miss uh it's
time to stop building hard whoopsies
I'll take that hook please how do i bill
why is the music so sweeping and
grandeur [ __ ] our building hammer I
can't I can't do it okay do it boss
Oh oh thank you thank you alright now I
can build building hammer can the not
back need to stop doing that that be
dead all right Wayne I'm going out there
I'm gonna go get some you can just screw
right off watch this [ __ ] bro moves
Wayne Brady ain't gonna get ain't good
yeah Wayne Brady ain't gonna get me oh
I'm on my raft alright
build craft alright okay now I've got a
building hammer oh wait no really what
gender existence didn't I
that's what you get thank you
I mean I don't know I always I always
mix up threats and compliments where's
Wayne Brady Wayne Brady's all the way
over there so I'm going for it I forget
why's named Wayne Brady but he
absolutely is named Wayne Brady that
shark is one hundo Posehn toe win
oh did it well I did it oh I did it it's
getting so peaceful so relaxing so nice
calm beautiful
crushing loneliness the only thing I
could ever hope for I guess I'll just do
more of this whomp lamp oh I've got a
big ol house what else can I build axe
that seems a Borden fishing rod oh that
probably Borden I am gonna need food and
water paddle your Afghan stuck this
what's it gonna get stuck on Wayne Wayne
that's right Wayne you better back off
whoa what is that what is that what is
that that not that I'm coming towards me
that is that coming towards me is that
what I could get stuck on why is an
island floating toward am i floating
towards the island oh [ __ ] well I this
changes things I suppose right anymore
and in pori I need more in Ventura
Hey Chow Wayne whoa Wayne whoa whoa dick
dick I guess I just need to spread as
wide as possible to kind of like
threaten that Island well there's gonna
be a problem this might be conundrum is
what is that over there says someone
else's raft I didn't even know there
were gonna be other people the whole
point of this is that I'm lonely and
nobody loved that's getting close hmm
that's gonna be a problem
pretty soon good thing Oh Wayne Brady
you piece of sh oh well I hope you're
happy you know I hope you're happy cuz
I'm not you know I'm not happy I just
gonna say that right out I'm not this is
a problem I'm gonna make a paddle I
don't know what good's gonna do but
scoop all right okay well about to land
ho
good you rethought it okay what's gonna
happen when I hit this island
nothing can I get on the island what I
can
oh that's so cool oh it's like a
persistent world ooh red flavor red
flower hell yeah
give me some black flower all right raft
wait whoa whoa hey whoa where do you
think you're going without me come on
now come on now let's go towards this
thing hello
could it be friends oh yeah oh I'm
really scooping it do pee on this one
friend Franco
look I'm not see crazy I am see normal
I'm see normal if you arson or Mille
closer you know you want to come to me
you want to say you like it - sighs I'm
out last I understand everybody get
rafted jealous of me whenever they see
hello you are now Martin mine got the
crate uh-oh no I want more I'm greedy oh
[ __ ]
I shouldn't have been grown have been
greedy sorry I was greedy but I got a
crit where'd that thing go we pretend go
this doesn't make any God where's
everybody okay I'm in the middle of
absolutely dick deadly I gotta get I win
I gotta get over here all right Oh
doodly doodly doodly Doo Lu Doo Lu
litter
I guess the trash flow is coming from
over here now unless it decided to spawn
in front of me no it's over there god
you're a trick it's over here Wayne
Brady's just throwing me for a loop and
I don't much appreciate that I'm Brady
being an [ __ ] well you got to be an
[ __ ] now why are you named Wayne
Brady ha oh god I'm little Hollow
it's so cool man they really improved
this why are there waves why does it
look like the waves are getting bigger
I don't like that at all also what the
hell are these things Oh PLAs I was not
really growing no way no no no no no no
no no so I wasn't really aiming for the
plastic I've only I'd known that I would
have done zit ghibli that is that
plastic that better be plastic twofer
I'm gonna get that one look at that
watch that what's this [ __ ] watch this
[ __ ] Oh jump jump shot they're actually
gonna get it I actually did I did not
think I was gonna get that one oh look
how skilled I am oh look at me I didn't
really need to do that but I did it
anyway are you plastic of yes please
pull the weight for this barrel the
donkey Oh more plastic well don't mind
if I do
[ __ ] [ __ ] you then go just think you're
gonna run away from me know the answers
you are not oh why Wayne oh you [ __ ]
Wayne you piece of [ __ ] those cost
plastic I do not have a lot of plastic
even though I know for a fact the ocean
is covered in plastic that's what
everybody knows cuz we made it that way
just in case we'd get trapped on a raft
and then have to live off the plastic
that's why we did it why else would we
do it oh no it's good night almost give
real skip whoops I'm gonna give real
scare tonight
oh it's beautiful Oh goddamn look at
that look at that that's beautiful
sure I'm glad people put all their [ __ ]
in barrels man that's really convenient
alright what else can we make I want to
make an axe oh wait I can make a robe
very crude nail sure wet brick wet brick
as opposed to what not wet brick got him
no eventually I'm gonna make where's my
where's my chair the [ __ ] music where
did you come from
I can research okay I'm about to die
from the lack of anything okay I need
water
real bad it's pretty oh god it's so pro
oh yes love that okay I have no water
I'm going to what I'm gonna do I need to
build a simple purifier yeah okay I'm
gonna make two of these all right you're
gonna go you there and why should have
made these sooner huh well I need to oh
I am very dying
okay plastic cup all right um filled
with seawater and place cup of seawater
place plank okay I'm probably gonna die
but alright okay well there's a problem
actually no don't drink why did you
drink that why did you drink that I
didn't want to drink that that was not
my idea to drink that Wayne Brady's is
gonna make fun of me now that I drank
that how long do these take to do I kind
of forgot that it was a important Oh
filled with fresh water drink hey Wow
look at me look at me oh look at me with
my big brain oh yes yes please somes
yes please II to me isms okay get weird
weird what by mad dog I've got my hook
my hook ok good thing I can make another
one of those holy [ __ ] I am I build one
of these let's put this right good god
it alright we're good
I didn't know this had limited
durability hood somebody should probably
keep it either survive it in this place
real hard guys I didn't even know Wayne
Brady you are gonna die if you come near
me again
ok now that I'm not gonna die
immediately I need to figure out a food
situation ok so we need to make whoa we
need to make Oh a fishing rod dad be
smart
make that I'm gonna make that no yeah
that's a good fishing rod and then we're
gonna make a grill oh hell yeah oh let's
build a grill baby grill baby grill Oh
al you all right Oh hell's to the yeah
give me you and give me you oh my god
I'm so good I am a god at this game oh
I'm so goddamn good all right so I'm
gonna fishy wishy Oh got it
got a raw mackerel put that baby on the
grill place a plank down two planks oh
you you ask top stop
just work it why is this not working hey
hey hey wait what why why did that why
did that not work why if he does that to
one of my oh I thought I was assuming
that I was gonna be somewhat safe but
apparently I'm someone not safe the ax
I guess the ax would be for when I if I
get to an island and I cut down a tree
maybe I don't know maybe breaking up the
[ __ ] that I have Oh what would even be
the point that oh okay that is then
there's gotta be like a once I build a
research table there's got to be like
something I could do then probably hard
it's hard no god damn it god oh I drank
seawater again because I'm an idiot
I can't daylight come I want to go home
sorry I'm getting crumpled I didn't mean
to get grumpy I didn't mean to yell at
you that's that's not why we're here
we're here to have a good time alone in
the ocean right have a good time oh dear
daylight come Oh Wayne Brady you don't
even think about it you do not even
think about that
where'd my mackerel go oh there it is
yum yum yum in my tum tum tum pour that
out fill drink fill drink ahh
see how easy it is there we go now we're
now we're cooking with gas there's a
another raft over there man I sure hope
these other rafts are from people that
were rescued and they didn't die
horrible deaths
alone on the ocean succumbing to the
elements and Wayne Brady here where's
all my barrels by the way are they gonna
stop giving me barrels now did they just
decide that I don't deserve barrels
that's okay yeah you know it's fine you
know I I don't really need barrels it's
just something that's incredibly useful
to me was it was this blueprint antenna
what for RESCUE BOTS crew rescue I've
reserved my myself to be in here for the
rest of forever that's just how this is
I think there's no other way to do it
like right there I just me and blah you
sack of choke it good you know what good
good you thought better of it raw
tilapia I'll put some broth Olivia there
okay now they go okay now that I got
that I got that out of the way I'm good
and we got some barrels coming our way
oh there's a big wave wow wow
whoa I don't like the smile on you I
wish I could whomp you what can I want
you whoa dad's is a big island yeah so
big island where's it getting kind of I
don't know about the waves are getting
kind of brother waves are kind of blare
guys well don't like them that big you
know I like good wave but then some big
waves are just saying you know eat this
tilapia haven't been able to get any
scrap metal oh that's why the waves are
getting kind of bit I'm it's raining
they put what are the weather in the
game okay well that's a problem
sharkbait wood and spur that's what I
was needing okay I need to make a spear
that's what's gonna kill this bad boy
okay all right did I miss any boy it's
all by Island oh whoa where were we will
ok research table I've got a researcher
to ball
I don't know what that's gonna do for me
but I've got it
and my raft is slightly girthier which
is all that really matters in life when
you really think about it and if you're
thinking about it louia I'm thinking
about it then you're obviously smart
like me
woo-woo-woo these waves are girthy just
like my draft Magee barrel will get you
and this plank to go I'm gonna get this
plastic ooh that's it so good I am a
triple Oh baby
all right well we got here do I put this
on that whoa whoa oh not this time Sonny
Jim not this time you're gonna get
Facebook spirit Oh Oh No
oh poor Wayne Brody oh no what why what
did I piss off piss off the Sharks the
Sharks somber knell sad gonna run away
his family just trying to chew some wood
well too bad not my wood why the music
why I'm not sad you can't make me sad
cuz I'm not sad you ain't gonna you
ain't gonna make me sad if that's what
you're trying to do cuz you ain't gonna
work I'm sad proof hmm I don't like that
I don't like that choir
I ain't sad it's just I'm not okay I've
farmed up a ridiculous amount of
material oh wow wow wow wow wow
research wow that's so good I think yeah
yes I don't know what it what the hell
did I just what did that do I'm not sure
what that did do I have to
oh oh oh I get it okay
so I've learned oh oh oh oh that's an
interesting way to do it okay wait let
me make sure I'm not missing anything
barrel-like all right we're good okay oh
and look at the waves are calming down
and I see a raft over there but I'm not
gonna go for it but other waves are
coming down I'm starting to learn things
so using my big old brain nobody can
appreciate it because nobody's here but
I'm using my big ol brain ain't that
nice say it's nice it is nice
thank you me a guy I learned a
collection net I need to make rope we're
doing good lights are going out again
but that's okay we've got more work to
do I'm gonna make some Nets I got to
make sure I'm pointing in the right
direction but if I just make these nets
no yeah there and there oh I'm gonna
collect some items dust real nice oh
this oh this is starting to become a
home oh this ain't just this ain't just
this ain't just a house this is a home
now that's nice that's real nice Wayne
Wayne Wayne Wayne whoa whoa whoa Wayne
Wayne oh four more parts uh that's right
that is right that can make a mower
collect hell yeah
oh yeah that's awesome alright now that
I got my resourcing operation started I
can start building for serials perfect
how about and them up I've got the big
bouncing the bales oh Island Oh Oh land
ho I don't know what they say some kind
of ho I did not a lady I want to be very
clear it's in this land it's like dirt
I found dirt hello Island oh is it a
fruit tree Oh that'd be so old it'd be
so good but I can't I'm on a diet
oh I'm gonna die mass starvation diet no
no no way no no no
nah you're gonna die soon you're gonna
die soon hate to say it but you're gonna
die soon is the way the world works
silly [ __ ] alright so we got a lot of
junk we need to start thinking about
what sale now that would be kind of cool
I need more palm-leaf I'm not sure how
good a sale would be like at all but oh
I'm sorry I let things get to me I take
every loss personally and I shouldn't do
that bird when can I kill and eat a bird
that's all I'm really hoping for is
worth a sweet succulent taste of bird
whoa whoa these sail waves are getting
kind of big don't know what that means
okay but I can make a sail now can nudge
you in the right direction what about
the wrong drew I like of this I like of
this alright let's open oh look at this
aw look at this look at this it's kind
of taking on my view but look at the
disk
Oh look at the disk let's see if we can
leave we can go this way I want to go
that other raft sail ho yeah screw that
other raft actually out of it I have no
desire I've no desire to see that other
raft and whatever riches it may entail
alright small crop plot I'm gonna need a
couple of these we're gonna need to get
our taters up and running there you go
there and you go right there okay we're
gonna put taters in you if I can get to
it
plant plant plant oh it does three
that's lovely let's do beats plant plant
plant oh that's really nice oh I need
some fresh water what kind of [ __ ]
is this
okay alright then it needs fresh water
oh all right then
know that and yeah something else needed
fresh water in this son of a [ __ ] okay
all right guess I'll just die I guess
I'll just starve and die I don't know I
didn't actually mean anything I'll die
oh you'll do don't worry about I'll die
yeah I'll die it's okay don't worry
about I'll die I'll eat these beets okay
no odd timing for music to suddenly pop
in little concerning kind of wondering
why isn't there all the time well you
know yeah we are booking it we're also
not getting nearly as much drops as I
was hoping we were getting alright let's
see what else we can make all right we
need rocks I got rock I got rock rope no
or did that metal yeah oh yeah oh
all these okay I got those oh [ __ ] what
was that
Oh huh what are that scrap hook that
sounds nice whoo I learned about
yourself
ah look at you I don't have enough scrap
for that but doll look at you where am I
gonna be more scrap oh I don't care look
at you you're cute faster more durable
it can be thrown farther yeah just like
your mom uh-huh can make paint oh that's
it seems unnecessary maybe I should make
some storage I probably need that that's
price sounds good Oh rotates smoothly
all right okay ah no no Wayne [ __ ] oh
yeah look good you did nothing you're
just such a piece of [ __ ] don't even
think about it I'll put you right there
okay I'm gonna put the flowers in there
this weird black seed in there
we got a cook mackerel I kind of forgot
about Ernie he did and yum yum yum come
to Papa
no that's not gonna come the pub came to
Papa all right well let's see here those
potatoes and beets are grown real good
like I'm gonna venture need to build
another one of those plots but for now
we're doing pretty good okay so what do
I need well I mean eventually I'd need
more collection nets but I don't even
have enough scrap to be able to make the
nails to be able to get that in the
first place maybe I could make myself a
bed that sounds nice maybe I deserve it
maybe I deserve a nice bed you know what
that's
real love early like oh nice bed right
there point down lay down
oh Dow sudden weird okay alright well I
get to contemplate my own mortality good
[ __ ] get [ __ ] Wayne Brady maybe the
least you know that's some that's some
alright could lay down look at the Stars
harvest hell yeah however so harvest me
harvest me do oh you're not ready to
harvest ok whatever bro nailed it oh I'm
so godlike Wayne your stay away from my
victories alright so he's going good I
got a I got a damn good base here I've
got a shockingly good base this is the
base and this is pretty good now the
only thing I can do to get this better
is just to make it wider but scrap metal
is really hard to come by apparently ha
ha Wayne Wayne Wayne how are you not
dead yet Wayne Wayne are you not dead
how in the hell can't repair this there
any way that I could repair this I need
to make more stuff ah repair one got him
got him got him alright let's see what
let's
oh [ __ ] let's see what this let's see
what this guy is all about yeah yeah we
might scrape some paint here I'm not
sure Allen could you all just the
gentlest of kisses justic okay I was a
little less gentle but then I thought it
was gonna be just the most gentle of
kids alright we're coming for you
prepare to be boarded
whatever that means um you'll get you
don't run you got some goodies over
there you got goodies I can't oh I know
goodies when I see goodies and you got
goodies come here you
what do you think you going where your
dinky guys waiting nowhere Oh nowhere
you ain't going nowhere can I break you
down with like an axe or something
there's a bed here pickup crate
oh that's just stop Oh scary scary
oh my god why would you do that what's
up what's up but the full way whoa what
the fake wood wood wood wood wood wood
freakin to be said what lay down okay
everything's still it's here
good dolly what the hell is that all
about I mean I know I was trying to eat
my stuff but me ain't gonna happen on my
watch
you crazy oh I can cook a potato forgot
I can cook potatoes why am i I'm twisted
I don't like that hello my untwist my
Scott damn it everything was going
smoothly I'm just gonna try to push can
i push it can i push it to twist it back
how do i how do i bushu is this just cuz
I hit something god dammit well now all
right well this sucks
okay anyway I am doing good I declare it
and if I declare it I'm dry I mean Brady
if I declare it then it's actually gonna
be true Wayne you don't even think about
it
ah so I'm gonna end this episode here
I'm the king hi I wasn't able to build
my screaming porch how do you build the
chair oh I want a chair wait wait that's
a lot of oh that's a lot of stuff I just
learned oh I like it
ah wait wait not that one not that one
you [ __ ] are you bigger wait did you
get bigger are you eating my wooden
getting bigger that makes no sense
all right anyway make this this go huh
all right this go oh how AM me do you
are in wrong spot remove you you are in
way of my glorious glory you go here you
throw us towards that and we not rotate
apparently okay now me put didn't know
how how do this
well no maybe wall wall wall sounds good
then put found douching nevermind not
that no I am confused okay whoa
I built wall can i bit why why no this
statute work how do i bill how do I
build da [ __ ] god dammit oh no oh no
wait um oh wait oh wait oh no no I've
somehow improved upon my screaming porch
by making it an enclosed screaming room
I've trapped myself in a box I have no
friends no one can hear my suffering I
am alone anyway I guess this is as good
a place as any day in this episode maybe
I'll pick this up if I can ever escape
from this room which I probably cannot
anyway thank you everybody somebody know
my crops well there you have it and now
I'm gonna dive dehydration so thank you
everybody someone for watching
also we're going to Australia in
November and Amsterdam in July tickets
are available at tortimer gobbler calm
death is slowly in closing in around me
so thanks again everybody for watching
let me know how he fought down the
comments and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]